avez-vous réellement confie jurassique
pas on parle évidemment de jurassic park
premier du nom le seul et l'unique avez
vous réellement compris jurassic park
croyez-vous avoir réellement compris le
film jurassic park
aujourd'hui on va se faire un petit
quizz pour cette analyse de séquences un
petit quizz pour voir jusqu'à quel point
vous avez compris le film alors c'est
pas un quiz dont le but est de
déterminer que je suis un meilleur fan
que vous parce que je connais mieux le
film c'est pas du tout ça la question
ce quiz en fait il va me permettre de
vous guider en fait vers une conclusion
vers une opinion que j'aimerais exprimer
à propos des film jurassic park de la
saga jurassic park en général et je me
disais que faire ça à travers quelques
petites questions ce serait sympa et
interactif
on voit là je vais vous poser deux
questions en réalité uniquement de
questions et ces questions elles vont ça
va être des questions à choix multiples
donc vous allez rentrer en fait le
numéro de la réponse que vous pensez
être la bonne donc je vais vous donner
trois réponses possibles il faudra
mettre le numéro dans les commentaire
voilà vous mettez dans les commentaires
le numéro de la réponse que vous pensez
être la bonne alors on commence
première question dans le film jurassic
park qui coupe le courant du parc
donc comme vous le savez dans le film
jurassic park toutes les clôtures
finissent par ne plus fonctionner quelle
est la raison de cette coupure de
courant
réponse une la tempête c'est la tempête
qui provoque la coupure de courant
réponse 2 c de nice nedry qui coupe le
courant afin de couper les systèmes de
sécurité de pouvoir accéder aux embryons
ou réponse 3 c'est monsieur arnold alors
vous pouvez mettre pause pour avoir plus
de temps pour réfléchir à votre réponse
ou vous pouvez carrément aller revoir le
film si ça vous dit on n'a jamais trop
vu jurassic park et donc la réponse
c'est monsieur arnold donc là je
m'attends à deux types de réaction de
votre part ceux qui vont de l'irb
annoncé de nice nedry et ceux qui vont
me dire mais c'est qui monsieur arnold
et voilà justement c'est que la coupure
de courant elle est faite par monsieur
arnold le personnage qui est campée par
samuel l jackson sous les ordres de john
amende
donc c'est john amendes qui dit à
monsieur arnold coupé le système
monsieur arnold couple système et quand
il leur lance le système ne redémarre
pas tout le courant est coupé
il faut aller redémarrer les fusibles
donc laissez là qu'il va dans justement
la remise et qu'elle se fait bouffer
dans la remise et c'est donc ellis
athlètes qui va finir pas pouvoir
remettre les fusibles à la fin du film
donc c'est monsieur arnold le personnage
campé par samuel l jackson qui coupe le
courant
enfin c'est plus une conséquences
malencontreuses du fait qu'ils coupent
le système qui coupe le courant donc la
bonne réponse était la réponse 3
beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est de
nice nedry qui coupe le courant pour
pouvoir accéder aux embryons mais ils ne
coupent que les systèmes de sécurité ne
coupent que les caméras et les portes de
sécurité
le courant fonctionne encore la preuve
les embryons l'aller les lampes autour
des embryons sont toujours allumée et il
a coupé aussi certains systèmes pour
pouvoir passer au travers de certains
enclos notamment l'enclos du dinosaure
où il va justement trouvé la mort et la
raison pour laquelle il a coupé le
courant dans certains enclos pour
pouvoir passer au travers c'est pour
pouvoir créer un raccourci pour pouvoir
aller plus vite sur les quais pour
pouvoir prendre le bateau bateau qui
démarre plutôt prévu à cause de la
tempête
voilà donc la tempête est responsable du
fait que dennis nedry coupe le courant
dans certains enclos qui est lui-même
responsable du fait que monsieur arnald
va couper le courant dans le parc
c'est la fameuse théorie du chaos voilà
un petit événement a provoqué une série
de catastrophes qui va affecter nos
personnages dans le film
alors maintenant deuxième question est
juste pour que vous puissiez y répondre
aussi dans les commentaires sans qu'on
confonde avec la première question les
propositions seront à b et c au lieu de
1 2 3 donc question numéro 2 le film
jurassic park est une critique à des
dérives du génie génétique b de l'homme
qui se prend pour dieu ou c'est de
l'automatisation donc là c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué je m'attends à
trouver deux écoles dans les réponses
donc l'école qui répondra à ou b et
l'école des petits malins qui ont
exactement anticipé où je veux en venir
et qui auront répondu c'est donc si vous
avez répondu à roubaix
vous avez raison dans le sens où les
dérives du génie génétique et l'homme
qui se prend pour dieu sont des thèmes
qui sont ouvertement abordée est
critiquée dans le film donc verbalement
abordé est critiquée dans le film sauf
que ces critiques viennent toujours de
ian malcolm et que malcolm c'est le
clown du film ian malcolm cl c'est ce
qu'on a de plus proche d'un comique
release dans le film c'est lui qui fait
les petites blagues et tout ce qu'il dit
à propos de la dérive du génie génétique
et de l'homme qui se prend pour dieu est
systématiquement tourné en ridicule par
un autre personnage
si vous vous rappelez la scène où ils
sont dans la salle où il ya les
diaporamas donc la scène du déjeuner ian
malcolm se fait reprendre par john
hammond qui le tournent en ridicule
immédiatement et il y à la fameuse scène
où il dit dieu créé les dinosaures dieu
détruit les dinosaures dieu créé l'homme
l'homme détruit dieu l'homme créé les
dinosaures et bien la fin de cette
tirade il est tourné en ridicule par
elie sattler qui dit le dinosaure mange
l'homme et la femme hérite de la terre
donc oui a et b sont abordés dans le
film
messi a et b étaient réellement au coeur
du film au coeur de ce que le film
critique alors ça voudrait dire que ce
sont les dinosaures le problème sauf que
les dinosaures n'ont jamais été le
problème dans jurassic park
les dinosaures ne sont que des animaux
dans jurassic park
ce ne sont que des animaux dans un zoo
qui finissent par s'échapper et ils
finissent par vivre leur meilleure vie
des dinosaures j'en veux pour preuve la
scène où le tyrannosaure se met à
chasser des galy minus dire il ne fait
que vivre sa vie des dinosaures une fois
qu'il s'est échappé le t-rex son but
dans la vie contrairement aux
spinosaures de jurassic park iii ou aux
dinosaures de jurassic world ce n'est
pas de pourchasser les protagonistes à
la sab le mans jusqu'à ce qu'ils crèvent
là et si john amende avait créé une
volée de condor sur cette île est bien
le problème aurait été exactement le
même
la tempête serait survenue aurait
précipité les plantes nedry qui aurait
désactivé les systèmes de sécurité et
certains enclos pour pouvoir accéder aux
embryons de condor et s en elle et
ensuite s'échapper le plus vite possible
ce qui aurait conduit monsieur arnold a
coupé le système pour pouvoir récupérer
le contrôle sur jurassic park le
problème de jurassic park
ça n'a jamais été les dinosaures et j'en
veux pour preuve la grille
l'histoire du film de monstres et de
tous les plagiats qu'il y a eu de
jurassic park où ils ont juste remplacer
les dinosaures par n'importe quel autre
monstre
donc il faut pas croire que les
dinosaures sont le problème dans
jurassic park le vrai problème de
jurassic park
c'est la malhonnêteté de dennis nedry
l'incompétence de monsieur arnold et le
fait que ce soit les deux seuls et
uniques informaticiens présents sur le
site à ce moment là le problème c'est
que le parc est complètement dépendant
de l'automatisation les voitures
fonctionne tout seul
la salle de contrôle fonctionne sous le
commandement de dennis nedry uniquement
qui est trop doué pour ne pas être
malhonnête et que son second c'est
monsieur arnold qui lui est incompétent
il n'arrive pas à retracer les commandes
de dennis nedry c'est ça le vrai
problème de jurassic park c'est
l'automatisation et c'est beaucoup plus
palpable dans le livre que dans le film
ça je suis d'accord mais
l'automatisation a toujours été le coeur
de la critique du film jurassic pas le
problème c'est le contrôle par
l'automatisation et la notion de
contrôle est aussi abordée verbalement
dans le film plusieurs fois
rappelez vous ils n'ont jamais eu le
contrôle john amende n'a jamais eu le
contrôle
il n'a jamais contrôlé dennis nedry et
dennis nedry est celui qui contrôlait
tous les systèmes alors maintenant
regardez vos réponses est ce que vous
avez eu tout bon ou pas mais là où je
veux en venir c'est que de toute façon
que vous ayez eu tout bon ou non que
vous ayez complètement compris jurassic
park ou pas vous êtes ici en train de
regarder cette vidéo parce que vous êtes
un fan de jurassic park et vous avez
apprécié jurassic park
même si vous ne l'avez pas compris
jurassic park s'apprécie même si on ne
le comprend pas moi j'ai vu jurassic
park quand j'avais sept ans j'étais
complètement largués par ce thriller
scientifique par le scénario de ce
thriller scientifique écrit par michael
crichton qui est l'un des plus grands
écrivains de thriller scientifique du
siècle dernier
donc je vais dire il n'y a pas de honte
à pas avoir compris jurassic park
moi-même je n'ai compris jurassic park
qu'après avoir poli la vhs paulilles dvd
et pauline blu ray des milliers de fois
quoi je veux dire je les ai poncet et
est maintenant seulement je peux me dire
ah bah oui le vrai but du film de juin
ce parc c'est pas de critiquer les
dinosaures c'est de critiquer
l'automatisation
mais voilà j'ai quand même réussi à
apprécier jurassic park
quand j'étais enfant parce qu'il ya
beaucoup plus dangereux racing parc que
son seul scénario
en revanche la saga jurassic world elle
bat c'est beaucoup plus dur de fermer
les yeux sur son scénario
la saga jurassic world elle il faut
débrancher son cerveau pour pouvoir
l'apprécier
est ce que vous comprenez la nuance
jurassic park s'apprécie même si on ne
le comprend pas mais débrancher son
cerveau est une condition nécessaire
pour apprécier la saga jurassic world et
jurassic park iii aussi par la même
occasion et c'est pour ça moi que je ne
supporte pas que les gens me disent ce
n'est qu'un film à chaque fois que j'ai
mais une critique à propos des film
jurassic world et en particulier si
c'est des critiques du point de vue de
l'aspect scientifique
on me répond ouais mais c'est qu'un film
c'est pas un documentaire
bah oui mais jurassic park aussi c'était
qu'un film et pourtant je les regarde et
je les regardais et enfants je les
regardais étant ado je le regarde
maintenant en tant que scientifique en
tant que paléontologue et jurassic park
qui me fait toujours kiffé et c'est pas
la nostalgie c'est juste parce que je
redécouvre des couches du scénario à
chaque fois qu'ils me font kiffer c'est
un thriller scientifique vachement bien
écrit jurassic park
alors que jurassic world c'est juste du
film de monstre de base c'est juste du
film de monstre de base série b à gros
budget et il faut littéralement
débrancher son cerveau pour pouvoir les
apprécier
je suis désolé mais jurassic park vaut
mieux que ça je conclurai donc en disant
qu'on ne devrait pas avoir à débrancher
son cerveau devant un film de la saga
jurassic park et c'est pour ça que la
saga jurassic world ne trouvera pas
grâce à mes yeux et c'est pour ça que je
ne prendrai jamais c'est juste un film
est pas un documentaire comme une excuse
jurassic park valait mieux que ça
j'attends de ses descendants qu'ils en
fassent autant
et les vrais fans eux le savent